hello freak bitches we've got to be able
to think more nuanced about these things
and instead of going well I don't trust
Fox News therefore I don't trust any
media therefore I only am going to go to
the site that keeps as you said
reinforcing what I already believe
oMG GMOs are horrible calm that's the
only place where I get my news well now
you're in an echo chamber yeah that's a
huge issue and the other thing that you
brought up there about political about
financial all the different motivations
all the different things the variables
that's also stuff that you have to try
to pay attention to and squeeze into
your head and that's the thing it's
impossible we need someone like you to
sort of break it down someone who has a
background in this particular area to
break it down in a way that we can
understand lokay I'm comfortable that
Cara Santa Maria is being honest with me
about this particular aspect of
depression in neural chemistry he's this
is her experience this is also what she
knows about the science behind it
because I have no motivation otherwise
nobody's paying me to say this and I
think that this is why we as you know
the listeners of the Joe Rogan
experience the listeners of talk nerdy
with Cara Santa Maria the the people who
are really involved in the next movement
of alternative and new media it is our
responsibility to continue to support
these kinds of programs and to continue
to speak up and become engaged and
involved because if we're not happy with
the way that traditional media is
handling things because they're playing
to the ratings and they're playing to
the lowest common denominator we can't
be passive about it we have to support
the news outlets and the organizations
and the podcasts and the web shows that
that we support we have to do our part
to make sure that those things don't
fail because the unfortunate thing is we
don't have the backers that they have
when people look at someone posing with
an African animal like a lion they I
think people look at and they feel like
they see a dead movie star because they
don't know like all you know of that
animal is sort of wildlife documentaries
and then cartoon versions and the Lion
King it's like you feel like you're
looking at that
in America we drive down the road and we
see just like contorted pulverized deer
carcasses yeah you can't escape it
yes yeah and so I feel like it's never
gonna be as offensive you know what when
someone sees a dead deer it's not as
shocking to them as be like it's the
animal from the movies right right and
they killed it
you know anthropomorphizing of an
animal's of real estate when it really
feels to people more like I remember a
friend of mine who worked in the
environmental movement I shouldn't say
that because I she was a conservationist
okay this is working the conservation
movement and she complained about half
jokingly about charismatic megafauna so
that so much mental energy of Americans
gets tied up in the preservation of
charismatic megafauna and those things
become such money sinks that we miss
opportunities to understand like this
vast suite of other creatures out there
that doesn't make it onto calendars and
she was guy if I remember I think she
was speaking of the amount of research
dollar and dollars and public interests
and things that go into wolves like
understanding wolves you know and
there's all the other animals that she
calls like non charismatic megafauna you
just can't get someone to like care
about them yeah yeah we'd say it's more
chaotic now than it has been in recent
memory I don't think I don't think
that's it that's not a big statement is
that what happens is it was just an ebb
and flow when it comes to these sort of
situations when when it comes to like
what's going on the world power
struggles then the power struggles that
resolve and then new resistance builds
up I mean is that in your experience how
things go well I think you you minimize
the chaos by being consistent and what
do I mean by that is is it you know in
as foreign policy as an example if your
foreign policy message is consistent and
and strong and clear and there's no
misunderstanding by either your allies
or the people that that are against us
then you can minimize the chaos that
exists if it's not consistent and
there's
confusion over where we stand and I'm
saying we because you know okay fine
we're still at the top of the food heap
whether people are comfortable with that
or not I don't know but so if we're not
consistent in that message then there's
confusion and that's where you start to
get problems because you start to get
people probing at the perimeter trying
to see what exactly is going on what
they can get away with we start getting
less leverage I mean you know we're
getting situation in the Middle East now
where countries are acting completely
without consulting with the US you
wouldn't have had that 30 years ago you
know it just wouldn't happen like what
wouldn't yeah Egypt acting in in what
they consider to be their own best
interest the Saudis the Saudis are
enormous ly pissed off at us still over
over what they view as the current
administration's failure to you know
work with them to try to resolve some
issues out in the Middle East and they
feel as if we've sort of abdicated
responsibility now whether we have or
not whether it's the right thing to do
or not I'm just saying from a policy
perspective you know if what we want to
do is be isolationist then be very clear
about that say this is all we're going
to do these are our parameters that's it
so everybody knows good well good with
it fine get on with it but you know the
mixed messages of the problem
I was selling mescaline for a little
while this guy this guy Andre the
blackest black er than your coffee and
tough and he was like in and out of
juvie homes and so he got me to sell it
to my friends so I would have a bad cuz
like a lot of my friends were into the
Grateful Dead and we go to a dead show
and I would just sell like a hundred
hits on mescaline and so so then one day
I guess I didn't even own money like he
would give me a bag and then I pay him
after I sold it and time wasn't really
up yet but I came home one afternoon and
I opened the front door out of my house
and I walk in and we lives in a pretty
nice house and my mom is sitting with
Andre in the living room having tea and
she never met him she just he just
showed up looking for me and I was like
oh what the fuck that's uncomfortable
that ended my my drug-dealing days ended
right there yeah you don't want Andre
embedded in your life Roger is banging
your mom
Oh because he would do that I know Andre
and she's on mask
I know Andre Andre would do it yeah he
lit up her drink
he had tea with her dropped a tab on her
tea right now the doors are playing dude
riders on the storm and you open the
door and he just fucking hammering them
from behind father yes son I want to
kill you and I walk in and he turns his
head and sees me and he gives me a look
that makes me have to fucking leave the
room eat mid-stroke doesn't even stop
banging my mom yeah yeah you don't want
to see this I don't want to see that
shit and I'm on mask a Jedi mind trick -
these are not the droids you're looking
for
Andre working every angle someone like
that banging your mom
oh that's dark yeah that would be brutal
let's go seeing his ass you know that
prison ass you don't know what it's been
through it's probably we got striated
muscle tissue all four out of two looks
terrifying right like you think about
the amount of force he could generate
with that ass oh my god yeah strong
thighs cuz he's walking around selling
drugs he's out on the street it's a
constant motion while cardio and now
he's got the back of it sighs ripping
and driving you know that drive you get
from the inside of your thighs when
you're real fucking well he's doing that
to her oh this is Charlotte but edit
that part out